Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Frau Arcevic. Heute bin ich Ihre zuständige Ärztin auf dieser Station und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Analyse-Geschiebrech führen.
Sind Sie damit einfach?
Ja, gerne.
Bevor Sie mir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden nennen, bräuchte ich einige persönliche Daten. Sie können jederzeit fragen, wenn etwas Ihnen unklar ist.
Wie sind Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Helmut Schmidt.
Schmidt mit DT am Ende?
Genau.
Könnten Sie mir Ihren Vornamen bestabieren?
Helmut, H, E, L, N, U, T.
Okay. Herr Helmut Schmidt.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Okay. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 4. Mai 1968.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 m groß und ich gehe 90 kg.
Okay. Vielen Dank für den Angalben, Herr Schmidt.
Welche Beschwerden haben Sie? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich komme heute in die Ambulanz, weil ich Brustschmerzen habe.
Das besorgt mich schon sehr.
Ich habe Angst, dass ich etwas am Herzen haben könnte.
Meine Nachbar ist vor kurzem an einem Herzentpack gestorben.
Deswegen möchte ich mich heute vorstellen, weil ich den Druck in der Brust nicht wegbekommen.
Was ist das, dass Sie das Brustbein haben?
Das Brustbein ist genau im gesamten Brustbereich.
Was ist das Brustbein?
Das Brustbein ist eigentlich hinter dem Brustbein.
Manchmal zieht man das auch ein bisschen in den Rücken rein.
Okay.
Wie lange haben Sie das Brustbein?
3 Monate.
3 Monate haben Sie immer dauerhaft oder kommen und gehen Sie wieder.
Das ist ein bisschen der Fall.
Das kommt und geht.
Wie lange dauert diese Geschmerzen?
Die dauern schon mehrere Stunden.
Die kommen und gehen wieder.
sich dieses Geschipre kurz unterbrechen.
Ihre Vitalparameter werden von meinen Kollegen gemessen und ich
verschreibe ihnen EKG.
Dann können wir unsere Geschipre fortfahren.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Schmidt.
Wie stark ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 0 bis 10,
wobei nur keine Schmerzen, sehr heftige Schmerzen entspricht.
Also manchmal ist das schon acht, aber eher so sechs, sieben würde ich sagen,
aber manchmal sind die sehr stark.
Sieben, aber manchmal sehr stark.
Wenn diese Schmerzen kommen,
maximal wie lange dauern diese Schmerzen?
Mehr als 20 Minuten oder weniger?
Weniger.
Also die halten so zehn Minuten ungefähr.
Okay, zehn Minuten und dann
ab und zu kommen, die Schmerzen nochmal.
Ganz genau.
Okay.
Und sind diese Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten?
Nein, ich habe mich kommen und gehen die.
Okay.
Dann immer schlimmer geworden, können Sie sagen.
Die sind gleich geblieben, aber
mich stört es, dass es bleibt und nicht weggeht.
Okay.
Können Sie ein Auslöser bemerkt, Herr Schmidt,
zum Beispiel bei Belastung oder bei Bewegung oder unter Stress?
Ja, unter Stress schon.
Es ist auch, ich war auch nachts damit auf, das stört mich auch.
Das ist nachts aufwache damit.
Und morgens habe ich die auch oft.
Morgen besonders.
Okay.
Und jetzt, wenn Sie diese Schmerzen bekommen haben,
was haben Sie gemacht?
Unter Belastung oder?
Ja, meistens mache ich nichts.
Oder ich trinke kurz, um euch zu beruhigen.
Und dann wird es auch besser.
Wenn Sie etwas trinken?
Ja, dann beruhige ich mich ein bisschen, weil ich
habe das Gefühl, dass mich das, dass die Schmerzen ein bisschen lindert.
Okay.
Und Sie haben schon erwähnt, dass Sie diese Schmerzen
in den Halsbereich ausstrahlen
und außer Hals und wie es Unterkiefer oder in den linken Arm
strahlende Schmerzen.
Ja, in den linken Arm strahlen die nicht, aber es ist eher so auch in den Rücken
zwischen den Schutterblättern auch.
Schutterblättern, okay.
Okay.
Und was versteckt Ihre Schmerzen?
Oder was lindert?
Da kann ich fragen.
Ja, also wie gesagt, wenn ich, wenn ich das trinke, scheint es besser zu gehen.
Wenn ich etwas kaltes trinke, dann fühle ich mich besser.
Kaltes trinken.
Lindert.
Ja.
Und nach dem Essen, verstärken sich die Schmerzen?
Ja, ich glaube schon.
Okay.
Haben Sie Herzrasen?
Herr Schmidt?
Nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay.
Und
war oder ist Ihnen ein Schwindel?
Ich habe kein Schwindel.
Okay, haben Sie schon mal, ja, bewusst sein verloren?
Nein, Gott sei Dank.
Okay, ja, Gott sei Dank.
Und ist Ihr, äh,
Ihr ist, sind Ihre Beine angeschwollen?
Oder Beinschwellung, haben Sie bemerkt?
Mich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay, Sie können Sie flach liegen
in der Nacht?
Ja, ich liege meistens eher so mit bisschen,
ich liege eher an der Seite.
Moment kurz, ich komme sofort.
Okay.
Ich liege eher so ein bisschen flach, also nicht flach, sondern ja.
Ja, Sie können flach liegen.
Ja, dann flach, dann flach, dann flach, dann flach.
Seitlich.
Ich flieg auf der Seite, seitlich.
Seitlich, okay.
Aber auf der Rückenseite, auf der Rückenseite,
auf der Rückenseite können Sie flach liegen.
Ja, ich habe kein Problem mit der Suche.
Okay.
Aber schlafen tu ich nicht so.
Okay, dann haben Sie Sot brennen?
Ja, manchmal.
Und heutzutage auch haben Sie?
Ich habe schon immer Sot brennen gehabt.
Immer.
Ja, kommt immer ab und zu wieder.
Mhm.
Okay, und Leidensunterhälse aufschtussen?
Ja, manchmal schon.
Mhm.
Okay.
Leidensunterblähungen, Unterblähbau?
Manchmal, manchmal wenn ich
etwas Salz gegessen habe.
Und
haben Sie Fibber, Steffrus oder Nachtschweiß?
Herr Schmidt?
Nein, nicht mehr.
Okay.
Wie ist der Appetit?
Leider zu gut.
Gut, okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit angewicht ab und zu genommen?
Nee, ich habe eher zugenommen.
Zugenommen?
Wie viel?
Weil ich habe mich nicht gewogen.
Mhm.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Haben Sie Überkeit?
Ab und zu.
Heute oder aktuell haben Sie?
Nein.
Okay.
Und haben Sie schon einmal erbrochen, Herr Schmidt?
Jetzt in den letzten drei Monaten?
Ja, mit diesen Beschwerden.
Nein.
Nein, okay.
Und Leidensunteratemnot?
Nein.
Aber manchmal, wenn dieser Schmerz kommt,
habe ich das Gefühl, als wenn ich schwer abkomme, aber dann geht das wieder weg.
Mhm.
Bei Schmerzen, manchmal, okay.
Und haben Sie Husten?
So ein Reizhusten habe ich.
Mhm.
Reizhusten, okay.
Keine.
Ich muss noch auf so Reusplan, so was machen.
Mhm.
Reusplan.
Ja.
Heiserkeit, meinen Sie?
Reusplan, meine ich.
Ah, ja, okay.
Und kommen die Essenreste in den Mund zurück?
Haben Sie Stimmstörung?
Heiserkeit?
Nein.
Nein, ich verstehe nicht.
Haben Sie Stimmstörungen oder Heiserkeit, meine ich?
Ja, und so, auf uns aber selten.
Okay.
Schlafen Sie gut?
In der letzten Zeit wegen, weil ich oft aufstehen muss,
weil ich das brennende Wurst habe.
Das Drucker für Wurst habe.
Ja, bekommen Sie diese Brustschmerzen besonders in der Nacht?
Auch, auch.
Auch, aber auch tagsüber.
Okay.
Wie ernähren Sie Schärfeessen, Schärfesessen oder pätiges Essen,
gebranntes, fertiges?
Wie ernähren Sie es?
Also ich versuche mich ausgewogen zu ernähren,
aber ich esse natürlich auch draußen.
Okay.
Bäufig draußen.
Nicht häufig.
Auch draußen.
Ja, okay.
Und essen Sie in der Nacht spät Nacht?
Ja, ich habe Schichtarbeit, ne?
Und dann muss ich auch mal nachts essen, ja.
Vor dem Schlaf, okay.
Ja, nicht vor dem Schlaf.
Also ich bin Schichtarbeiter und ich habe auch Nachtschicht,
zum Beispiel.
Und dann muss ich auch nachts essen.
Es ist immer so, wenn wir unterschiedlich.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Lagerist.
Okay.
Ja.
Jetzt komme ich zu Ihren Vorerkrankungen, Herr Schmidt.
Haben Sie dauerhafte Erkrankungen?
Ich habe Blutotruck.
Seit wann?
Das ist schon seitdem ich, ja, 45 bin ja fast zehn Jahre schon,
neun Jahre oder elf Jahre schon ungefähr jetzt.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und noch andere Krankheiten?
Ja, ich habe hohe Kulisterinwerte.
Und ansonsten ist mir nichts bekannt.
Okay.
Und seit wann leiden Sie an hohe Kulisterinwerte?
Oh, auch seit ungefähr,
dann hat er mein Hausarzt damals festgestellt.
Kann man zehn Jahre sagen.
Ungefähr so, ja.
Ungefähr, okay.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Nein, auch nie.
Mhm.
Ja, okay, das ist wirklich nicht.
Und welche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Ich nehme Kanasatana ein,
Amlodipine nehme ich ein,
Moxolidin nehme ich ein.
Die letzte können Sie noch mal mit.
Moxolidin.
Dann nehme ich noch Paracetä ein
und ich noch für den Kulisterin Atavastatin ein.
Kennen Sie die Dosierung, alle Dosierung?
Aber ich nicht im Kopf.
Okay, nehmen Sie die Medikamente Liste dabei?
Ich gehe auch nicht dabei.
Okay, können Sie mir Ihren Hausarztnamen verraten?
Damit kann ich von...
Das ist Herr Paul, Dr. Paul.
Paul.
Okay, das kann ich mit Herr Paul Kontakt aufnehmen.
Und sind Ihnen irgendwelche Allergen bekannt, Herr Schmidt?
Ich habe nur eine Hausjob-Allergie, sonst nichts.
Wie önset Sie?
Niesen, Jugendkreis, Augen tränen, Nase zu.
Okay, Augen tränen.
Dann okay.
Und sind Sie vorstellig geimpft, Herr Schmidt?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Haben Sie Ihren Impfungen machen lassen?
Welche Impfungen?
Zum Beispiel Corona-Impfung-Könnte sein,
oder die andere Impfungen Erfrischen, Impfungen-Könnte sein.
Welche?
Die Kinderkrankheit-Impfungen, zum Beispiel Tetanus-Impfung,
Musemia, Alletzen, Jahre, Erfrischen lassen.
Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Corona habe ich mich vor drei Jahren zu letzten Jahren.
Vor drei Jahre...
Es war eine Zeit, ich glaube.
Okay, Let's say, Impfung, ha benzi.
Vor drei Jahren.
Ich glaube, vor drei Jahren war das.
2021.
Okay, dann, danke.
Und waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Ich war in Holland.
Holland, okay.
Ansonst keine.
Ansonst war ich in der letzten Zeit nicht.
Okay.
Und jetzt komme ich zu Ihren Lebensgewohnheiten,
Herr Schmidt, auch in Sie?
Ja.
Wie häufig und was auch in Sie seit wann?
Ja, ungefähr eine Packung zu Girektrauschen.
Täglich und seit, ungefähr wie viele Jahre.
Seit, weiß ich nicht, seit 30, 35 Jahren.
Okay, das ist aber zu viel.
Ich würde Ihnen unbedingt empfehlen, damit aufzuhören.
Aber nicht so leicht.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich weiß, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Wenn Sie wollen, wir können Sie dabei unterstützen.
Ihr im Krankenhaus?
Ja, wir haben alle Abteilungen in diesem Krankenhaus.
Wenn Sie wollen, nach unserem Gespräch können wir da besprechen.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ab und zu, so jede zweite Woche, ungefähr.
Wie viel trinken Sie und was?
Ja, meistens trinke ich Bier, wenn wir uns mit unseren Freunden treffen.
Okay, ja.
Vielen Dank.
Und nehmen Sie diese letzte Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine ultimäßige Frage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie einen Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein.
Okay, das freut mich.
Und jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Familie sprechen.
Leben Ihrer Eltern noch?
Nein, beide verstorben.
Okay, tut mir leid.
Und woran sind Sie verstorben?
Autounfall.
Wann war das?
Das ist schon früh gewesen.
Das war vor ungefähr 20 Jahren.
Das war, glaube ich, 2004, muss es sein.
Okay, davor hatten Sie eine Behinderung auf der Erkrankung?
Ich?
Nein, hatten Sie meine Eltern.
Also Sie einhatten Diabetes gehabt, meine Mutter?
Und die hat auch in Soligen gespritzt.
Und mein Vater, soweit ich weiß, hat er nichts Billes gehabt.
Er hat ab und zu Schmerzmedikamente genommen,
weil er Rhythmischmerzen hatte, aber ansonsten,
soweit ich weiß, hat er keine Vorerkrankungen relevanten.
Ja, okay.
Dann haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ich habe eine Schwester, ja.
Eine Schwester?
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, sie ist 35, sie ist eigentlich so gesund.
Das ist ein psychischer Problem, aber sonst geht es jetzt ganz gut.
Okay, das ist schon ein Problem.
Und sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Schmidt?
Ich bin geschieden.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe einen Sohn.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, das freut mich.
Und Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie sind lager,
haben Sie Stress, weil der Arbeit oder die Infrarwärter...
Wer hat keinen Stress auf der Welt?
Ja, Sie haben recht, natürlich.
Das ist so.
Und jetzt bin ich fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Herr Schmidt, möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, also, was meinen Sie?
Kann ich tatsächlich so gefährlich,
dass ich, habe ich was am Herzen?
Oder weil ich bin wirklich besorgt,
mein Nachbar ist vor Kurzem,
mein Herz ist einfach verstorben, der war auch sehr jung.
Das kann ich gut verstehen.
Aber es ist zufüge etwas genauer zu sagen,
aber natürlich, das ist vom Herz herr-...
nach Ihren Angaben habe ich einen Verdacht auf
Herr Coronar Herzkrankheit.
Das ist Herzgefäße Verengung, Krankheit.
Deswegen bekommen Sie die Szenar-...
das kommt vom Herz, ja, es könnte sein.
Aber natürlich andere Krankheiten sein,
wie Magenbeschwerden oder Magengeschwörer,
Reflexkrankheit zum Beispiel.
Deswegen bräuchte ich,
sie körperlich zu untersuchen und Blut abnehmen,
dann einige wildgebende Verfahren.
Dann kann ich mich dann auch noch ein bisschen
genauer sagen, was Sie haben.
Sie warten Sie kurz, ich komme zu Ihnen gleich.
Alles klar.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe Fragen.
Bitte schön.
Herr Schmidt, hat Ihre Beschwerden in den letzten 3 Monaten
in Dauer und Intensität zugenommen?
Ja, ich habe noch eine Frage.
Es tritt häufiger auf, aber es ist nicht schlimmer.
Und wie viele Stücke können Sie ohne Schmerzen stellen?
Also kann ich eigentlich ganz gut laufen.
Ich wohne im 4. Monat, ich schloss, ich habe jetzt keine Probleme.
Okay, danke.
Eine Frage.
Als Besuch auf dem Herz,
oder nicht?
Ich war, zuletzt war ich vor 2 Jahren beim Hausarzt,
ansonsten lasse ich mir immer meine Medikamente verschreiben.
Ich denke alle Fragen,
die haben ich schon gemacht,
die haben ich schon gemacht.
Können Sie als Erstes anfangen, Herr Schmidt?
Ich habe schon gemacht,
ich habe schon gemacht,
ich habe schon angefangen.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag, lieber Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute mit einem neuen Patienten das Anamnese-Geschiebreich geführt
und würde gerne Ihnen den Fall vorstellen.
Haben Sie dafür kurz gesagt?
Ja, bitte.
Es handelt sich um Helmut Schmidt.
Er ist seit 1650 Jahren,
am 14.988 geboren,
1,75 m groß und 90 kg schwer.
Herr Schmidt stellte sich heute
wegen seit 3 Monaten bestehender,
schleichender,
aufgetretener,
wellenförmiger, drückender und brennender
retrosternaler Tora-Kaligi
mit Ausstrahlung in den Herzbereih-Valionsfonds.
Er ordnet die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerz-Kala
6 bis 7, ob manchmal 8 von 10 ein.
Der Schmerz dauert
weniger als 20 Minuten,
ungefähr 10 Minuten.
Als Auslöser berichtete der Patient
Stress.
Wenn er etwas trinkt,
lehnt sich der Schmerz.
Als Dörfer hinaus leidet der Patient
als Begleitzentrum
unter Angst.
Und Meteorismus,
Apuntzureguritation und Pyrosis.
Die Fragen nach Herz.
Pyrosis, alte Lateinisch-Wörter.
Sie haben sich nicht verwendet.
Wir müssen die Wörter, Pyrosis,
Indochter nicht verwendet.
Zutrennen bleibt.
Als Dörfer,
leidet der Patient als Begleitzentrum
unter Angst.
Und Meteorismus.
Die Fragen nach Beinodem,
Tachikardi, Vertigo wurden verneint.
Die Frage,
wie die Patient lebt.
Die Begleitzentrum
zeigt,
wie die Begleitzentrum
verneint.
Und wie die Begleitzentrum
wird verneint.
Die Frage, wie die Begleitzentrum
verneint.
Wie viel Ja ist es?
Ja, ich glaube,
das ist viel.
Ja, schon übergewichtig.
Okay.
Und
Sie haben den Insomni,
heutzutage und Reizkosten.
Schlafstörung, ja,
nicht Insomni, Schlafstörung.
Eine richtige Insomni,
er kann ja schlafen wahrscheinlich,
aber er wacht damit auf.
Ja, das stören ihn einfach nur.
Nur Schlafstörung, okay.
Und
Herr Schmidt ernährt sich,
ausgewogene, aber
er esse
spät Nacht häufig.
Als Vorerkrankungen.
Warum?
Weil er
Arbeiter,
nach Dienst, nach Schicht.
Genau, Schichtarbeiter,
das ist wichtig.
Als Vorerkrankungen,
sei in beiden Patienten,
Arteria hipertoni,
seit ungefähr
10 Jahren und
hyperlipidemie,
seit 10 Jahren bekannt.
Der Patient
sei bisher noch nicht operiert
worden.
Die Medikamente an einem Nase ergab,
die Einnahme kann des Arter
am Lodipin
mit Moxolidin,
Hydrochlorotiasit und Atorvacitatin
die unbekannte
Dosierung von
Patienten.
Dies bedrückt, werde ich
mit dem Hausarzt kontaktieren.
Beim Patienten
Hausstaballergie
bekannt,
die sich
Rhinokonduktivitis äußeren
und
der im Status sei vollständig
vor drei Jahren
mit Covid-19.
Die Reise in der Reisanamnese
sei der Patient
in Holland gewesen,
ansonst unauffällig.
Herr Schmidt sei
Raucher
mit einer Packung
täglich seit 35 Jahren,
das beträgt
35 Peckiers
und er trinke
Alkohol via
am Wochenende.
Der Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
In der Famine Namnese
seien
die Eltern
wegen eines Autounfalls
vor 70 Jahren
verstorben.
Dafür habe
die Mutter an Diabetes mellitus gelitten
und
der Vater
sei gesund gewesen.
Und
er habe
eine gesunde Schwester
nur psychologische Probleme
haben.
Herr Schmidt sei geschieden,
habe
einen gesunden Sohn
und sei
lagerist vom Beruf
und immer stress
bei der Arbeit.
Nach diesen anamnestischen Angaben
habe ich
erstmal einen Verdacht auf
Corona-Herr-Angina-Pectoris
als
Diagnose in Betracht
kommen
Gastro-Ödefragil,
Flugs-Krankheit
Ulkosventrychli
und
Autisektion
in Betracht
und Ulkosventrych.
Es ist schon sehr,
sehr weit hergeholt.
300 in die Beschwerden
hat, dass wir
das Leben wahrscheinlich
haben.
Was ist die Differenzialdiagnose?
Sie sind gut, sehr gut.
EKG haben sie gemacht, das war
unaufregig gewesen.
Was ist wahrscheinlich
Angina-Pectoris
oder ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit
ein Flugs-Gastritis?
Was ist wahrscheinlich
Ihrer Meinung nach?
Trotz normaler EKG
könnte auch
Angina-Pectoris sein.
Das ist wahrscheinlich.
Was ist wahrscheinlich?
Das oder das?
Was glauben Sie?
Sie glauben, Angina-Pectoris ist wahrscheinlich.
Ja,
weil, als Vorerkrankung
Hyperlipidemia
und Atelierhypertonie
und auch
Familiengeschichte Diabetes mei Lütus
steht.
Wir haben vollkommen Recht, man muss
wissen,
es ist ein Risikopatient,
richtig?
Wenn Sie, aber das nochmal zurückverfolgen,
was Ihr erzählt hat.
Welche Beschwerden hat Ihr, wann hat Ihr die Beschwerden?
In der Nacht.
Jetzt in Ruhe oder bei Belastung?
Beide.
Nein, bei Belastung auch?
Nein.
Bei Belastung auch? Ja, ich habe auch
Belastung, Stress.
Ich habe auch den Treppen hochsteigen.
Okay.
Was Sie erzählt haben,
erwarten mit den Schmerzen nachts auf.
Er hat die Beschwerden morgens
mehr.
Wenn er etwas bringt, ist es besser.
Nach den Essen
ist es auch öfters.
Richtig.
Sie haben jetzt nicht gefragt,
ob er Sport macht.
Das wäre noch gut gewesen,
vielleicht in der Anamnese.
Wenn Sie auch fragen können,
machen Sie Sport,
haben Sie die Beschwerden auch,
wenn Sie Sport machen,
wenn Sie Fahrrad fragen,
wenn Sie Spazierengegänge,
wenn Sie Treppensteigen,
hat der Kollege gefragt.
Um diese Belastung abhängige Schmerzen
auszuschließen.
Zum Beispiel,
wenn Sie den Verdacht,
ob eine Aninepektus haben,
sollten Sie auf jeden Fall fragen
bis eine stabile Aninepektus ist.
Natürlich haben Sie recht,
es könnte ein instabiler Aninepektus sein.
Seit 3 Monaten
ist das ein bisschen unwahrscheinlich.
Aber die Beschwerden,
die der Patient äußert,
sind eigentlich fast eindeutig.
Aber Sie haben recht,
man muss Aninepektus
aufgrund der
Vorerkrankungen
und seinem Risiko,
das er hat, mit Übergewicht,
Hochdruck, mit 4-5 Medikamenten,
Übercholesterinamie,
Stress, Schichtarbeiter,
das muss man im Auge behalten.
Aber die Wahrscheinliche Diagnose
ist, glaube ich,
eher das Zweite, was Sie gesagt haben.
Refluxesophageitis,
eventuell Gastrippis,
vielleicht hat eine Iatus hernia,
also eine hernia,
Axiale hernia,
vielleicht, weil er berichtet,
dass er nachts,
das stört ihm nachts,
dass er aufwacht und sagt,
ja, ich wache mit den Schmerzen auf,
die dauern 10 Minuten,
dann trinke ich etwas und dann geht es mir wieder besser.
Ja, okay.
Oder was sagen Sie dazu?
Sie haben recht, ja.
Auch dachte ich,
ich bin in der Mitte,
aber trotzdem in den Halsbereich,
Ausstrahlung auch,
das ist deswegen...
das ist der schlimmsten Aus.
Und natürlich sollte man das untersuchen
mit des EKG,
mit des Ulzerschall, mit des Budapname.
Man muss das auch im Betracht ziehen.
Wie können Sie denn jetzt,
oder was würden Sie mit den Patienten
jetzt machen, diagnostisch?
Erst mal würde ich den Patienten
körperlich untersuchen,
Vitalparimentarmission,
dann Bauch auskultieren
und dann
palpiere ich das Abdormen
ich erwarte Druckschmerzen
im Epigastrium
und
auch die andere
Ursachen auszuschließen
auch Abwehrspannung
oder die andere
Palpationen
auch durchführen?
Wie können Sie denn den Patienten
oder wie können Sie Ihre Diagnose
erhärten,
unterstützen,
die Sie in der Mitte haben?
Wie können Sie die Diagnose
herten, unterstützen
wenn Sie
welches Medikament den Patienten geben?
Wann müsste er sich besser fühlen?
Das ist Probe
Therapie könnte sein
Protonpomper
Protonpomper, werdet
ich probieren.
Das ist eine Probe-Therapie
auch kann man durchführen.
Normal intravenös
oder wie würden Sie machen?
Beide geht, aber intravenös
vieler wäre besser.
Travino, geht schneller.
Da könnte man gucken, ob ich die Schmerzen wiederbekomme
oder nicht bekomme.
Würden Sie den Patienten aufnehmen?
Wenn ja, welche Bootabladen würden Sie machen?
Ich würde erstmal
stationär aufnehmen,
weil ich habe schon
auch die phranseal Diagnose
Herzprobleme stehen.
Deswegen
muss ich das ausschließen
und Labor-Untersuchung
Blutbild-Entzündung
Parameter
auch Kardiak-Parameter
werde ich beurteilen
einmal und
die andere
Cholestas-Parameter
und Amylase-Lipase
die andere
Ursachen auszuschließen.
Und dann als
Apparativdiagnostik
werde ich dann Abdominalzono-Graphie
durchführen
um diese Cholestitis
oder Pancreatitis
auszuschließen
und werde ich ÖGD
veranlassen.
Richtig. Was kann man noch machen,
wenn er stationär ist?
Als Therapie oder
Diagnose.
Sie haben das ja gesagt, man kann ja noch
das Herz abschicken,
die Ultraschall vom Herz machen
und das Herz abschicken.
Jetzt haben Sie die Verlachtsdiagnose
der Fluchtsoße vergetest zum Beispiel.
Müssen Sie diesen Patientenstationen
aufnehmen?
Nein, wenn
die leberst bedrohliche
Pernasdiagnose
schon
ausgeschlossen werden,
werde ich
andere Therapienambulanz durchführen.
Was würden Sie
ausschließen?
Das ist etwas gelbungsgefährliches.
Ich meine,
Angina pectoris
oder die Corona-Herz-Krankheiten
das ist sicher
eine ganz lösungskrankheit.
Wenn der Patient sagt,
ich möchte aber nicht stationär bleiben
und dann können Sie aber, Sie haben
die Aufgabe in der Ambulanz
einen akuten Myocardinfarkt
auszuschließen.
Dann können Sie den Patient wieder nach Hause lassen.
Sie sollten
auf jeden Fall
Troponin abnehmen.
Wenn es möglich ist,
2-mal, so innerhalb
von 3 Stunden ungefähr,
oder 2 Stunden,
ob es ein Troponin-Anstieg gibt,
muss man bei den Patienten aber nicht wirklich
machen, aber kann man machen,
weil der Patient die Beschwerden schon seit 3 Monaten hat.
Und dann nochmal
eine KG schreiben, ob es eine KG-Veränderung gibt,
dann kann man
und wenn der Patient unter PPI
es ihm besser geht,
kann man auch den Patienten
eine Ambulanz belasten
und sagen, ich empfehle
eine ambulante PPI Therapie
plus zeitnah
ÖGD.
Kann man machen.
Also, weil er die Beschwerden nicht
jetzt hat, wenn der Patient
gesagt hätte, ich habe die Beschwerden
seit 3 Stunden,
dann würde ich ihn erstmal nicht nach Hause
lassen. Richtig?
Ja.
Nein, nicht nach ÖGD.
Nein, in Fartauschluss.
Eine Reflexösie vergetest
ist nicht lebensgefährlich.
Normalerweise.
Richtig? Ja, richtig.
Und wenn es ihm unter PPI besser geht,
kann man den Patienten
mit hochgotussierter PPI Therapie
erstmal nach Hause lassen.
Wenn aber die PPI Therapie
nicht ausreicht,
dann würde ich ihn schon stationär aufnehmen,
weil immer noch die
Wahrscheinlichkeit einer
Pettos oder eines Ulkus
besteht.
Und das Ulkus sollte man für eine gewisse Zeit
mit intravenöser
PPI Therapie behandeln, auf jeden Fall.
Ja.
Ich will nicht nur damit sagen, dass man
nach einem Infarktausschluss
den Patienten auch wieder ambulant belasten kann,
wenn man sich der Diagnose
sicher ist.
Aber besser ist es mal zu empfehlen,
bleiben Sie hier,
wir möchten den im Tag
oder wir müssten Sie doch beobachten.
Okay.
Gibt es Fragen
oder Anregungen?
Auch haben wir
gastroesophiekeale Flügel verdacht,
haben
für Ulkusventur-Kile
oder Helicobacter Pylori
und Ersuchungen sollen wir machen.
Selbstverständlich, wenn der Patient
stationär bleiben möchte, ja.
Aber ansonsten können Sie das ambulant
empfehlen oder sagen heute
ich habe keine Betten auf Station,
Sie können heute nach Hause, aber kommen Sie
morgen zu dem Termin für die
ÖGD zum Beispiel, die mit biopsierten
Marme. Auf jeden Fall kann man machen.
Okay.
Holfige Frage, Herr Hodja.
Wenn die Helicobacter Pylori
Laban interzuchung
entstätigt oder stätigt,
was machen
Sie, was können Sie empfehlen
für Therapie?
Also mittlerweile gibt es ja
also wenn ich im Labor
macht man das eigentlich weniger.
Man macht das eher
mittels
wie heißt das, mittels
biopsi.
Und wenn Sie dort
letztendlich
eine Helicobacter
feststellen,
dann muss man überlegen, ob man
eine Eradikation macht.
Eradikationstherapie
sollte man machen.
Und man macht die heutzutage
mit
Bismuth
mit Tetrazyklin
und Metronidazol.
Warum? Weil es diese
Klaritromizil
Resistenz gibt mittlerweile.
Okay.
Ja, können Sie
wiederholen?
Ja,
es gibt
die Therapie Pylera.
Pylera
ist für die Therapie
für Helicobacter Pyloris
zugelassen. Das hat
Bismuth
Tetrazyklin
Metronidazol
und dann noch Pantoprazol.
Okay.
Soll ich das in meine Chat reinschreiben?
Nein, er ist
eine Therapie.
Ja, das ist mittlerweile die
Ersten in Therapie tatsächlich.
Man
empfiehlt tatsächlich das hier.
Also nicht mehr diese
Französisch- oder Italienisch-
Es gibt die
diese Klaritromizil Resistenz.
Insbesondere auch bei Patienten aus
der Türkei oder so, da gibt es
diese Resistenz tatsächlich.
Man empfiehlt Bismuth.
Bismuth.
Wir hier Gastroenterologen unter uns haben.
Können die bitte auch mitmachen.
Weil ich weiß, wird das empfohlen.
Bismuth, Tetrazyklin
und Metronidazol plus PPI.
Okay.
Wo kann ich das in die Reise schauen?
Der Patient
nimmt
Moxonidin
Zentral
Antipelthansyver.
Ja.
Er hat wahrscheinlich ein sehr
einzustellenden Blutton.
Okay.
Man muss natürlich überlegen,
warum hat er diesen Reflex?
Eventuell über Gewicht,
Schichtarbeit, falsche Ernährung.
Vielleicht trinkt er doch mehr Alkohol
und sonst. Oder er hat
Medikamenten, die ihm auf den Magen schlagen.
Ja, vielleicht nimmt er auch
Ibuprofen ein, an wen ich gefragt.
Wissen wir nicht. Ja, vielleicht hat er
eine NSRL Typ C Gastritis.
Wissen wir alles da nicht.
Aber wahrscheinlich hat er eine Reflex-
also vergesst
aufgrund Alkohol, aufgrund von
Stress, Beschiedenheit,
schlechten Arbeitsbedingungen,
ein bisschen Realistik.
Haben wir noch eine Frage.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Muss man
muss man
in diesem Fall
eine Lungenröntgen machen?
Kann man machen.
Muss man aber nicht unbedingt machen.
Aber kann man machen in der Notaufnahme?
Kann man machen.
Er hat ja prinzipiell keine Luftnot.
Richtig.
Er hat keine Luftnot. Er hat nicht gesagt,
ich habe Luftnot.
Er sagt nur, nur wenn ich die Schmerzen bekomme,
dann habe ich kurz Luftnot und kann ich atmen.
Wahrscheinlich, weil der Reflex
da ist, weil es brennender ist.
Aber man muss es nicht machen,
aber man sollte, man kann es machen.
Und wenn er stationär
aufgenommen wird, würde ich es
für die
zu kompletierenden Diagnostik auch machen.
Ja,
eine
Lu-Kanzler oder
die Playwright-Effision
aus der Szene.
Ja, genau, man kann es machen, natürlich.
Ich hatte ja auch ein Luftknoten
der
die Speiseröre zusammenrückt oder so was.
Wissen wir es nicht.
Keine Frage.